previously on hunter x hunter gone left
his village to walk in his father's
footsteps while trying to pass the
hunter exams he meets lyorio kurapika
and killua
after passing the third exam phase the
group arrives at the fourth phase
location your favorite phase from that
arc the badge phase
they must steal their opponent's badges
gone managed to steal a badge from the
hizoka but at what cost in the end not
only did hazoka take the badge back but
also gone's diggity he threw it back to
the young lad telling him to keep it
until he becomes stronger so one day he
can fight him the story continues killua
calling out amore who's been stalking
him for a long time to show himself
since he won't give an opening attack
however emory remains still and
continues to hide because his plan is to
attack kilauea while he is asleep
impatient killua decides to come over to
him and frightening amore suddenly omori
and imori appear to see if their
youngest brother has finished taking the
badge upon seeing that amore hasn't
beaten up kilauea yet they yell at him
and force him to do it
afterward amore approaches kilauaa he
asks killua to give his badge and he
won't hurt him if he does
kilauea replies by insulting him
imori then kicks him and sends him
flying backward however kilowatt gets up
quickly and takes out amore's badge from
his pocket
realizing that it is not his target he
asks the older brothers if his target is
one of them amore and umori realize that
they are not dealing with an ordinary
kid they tell the youngest brother to
get information
meanwhile hanzo is seen watching from
the shadows that a fight is about to
begin
before the amore brothers can make a
move kilowatt flies and suddenly appears
behind amory taking him as a hostage
upon realizing that amore is not his
target he asks you more to hand over his
badge
after he receives it he throws the other
badges hundreds of feet away
then he bids farewell and vanishes
hanzo quickly runs for the badge that
killua threw and grabs it but he ends up
having the wrong badge since kill on
noticed he was there and quickly swapped
the badges before he threw it meanwhile
kurapika and lyorio are seen behind the
bushes they are trying to see if anyone
is back at the starting point to catch
guns suddenly shows up and lyorio
explains that they are looking for
examining number 204-6 ponzu
gohn offers his help to find her by
following her sense since she is known
for using drugs that must have a strong
odor after walking for a long time they
finally reach her location lorio decides
to enter the cave alone while gone and
karapika wait outside inside the cave he
meets bourbon and ponzu from the outside
god and kuropika hear leorio's voice and
they instantly run into the cave to find
leorio sprawled on the ground with snake
bites all over his body ponzu explains
that they cannot leave the cave because
bourbon had already set a trap when
someone tries to exit his snakes will
attack them
ponzi reveals that she had already
killed bourbon meaning they are all
trapped inside the cave
kurapika figures out how bourbon died by
looking at his wounds
ponzu's target was bourbon and she
explains their fight involving her bees
ponzi gives up on her desire for passing
the exam and waits for the examiners to
rescue her through a tracking device
attached to their badges to find their
exact locations
however the three can't afford to wait
for the exam to end as poison runs
through lyorio's body due to the snake
bites gone decides to fearlessly
sacrifice himself in order to search
bourbon to find an antidote the snakes
from bourbon surround him and attack him
but he successfully finds the medicine
due to gone's courageous act both he and
leorio are saved gone recovers quickly
and asks ponzo about her sleeping gas to
make all the snakes sleep so they can
escape the cave he requests a trade with
bourbon's badge which he got along with
the medicine in exchange for her
sleeping gas ponzu agrees but it will
take five minutes for all the snakes to
fall asleep stating it is impossible for
someone to hold their breath for more
than five minutes however gone brags
about his record the gas is released and
gome holds his breath to stay awake gon
carries all three of them outside and
successfully escapes the cave he gives
bourbon's badge to ponzu but takes her
own badge for a service fee while she is
still unconscious as kuropika lurio and
gon each have six points of their own
and the fourth phase of the hunter exam
ends all the participants who pass are
taken to their next destination
the chairman along with all the
examiners discuss the final phase of the
exam and the chairman wants them to go
through a peculiar fight but before that
the chairman holds an interview with
each examinee and asks them who they'd
want to fight and who they would not
want to fight
each of them gives an answer and after
the interview the chairman reveals the
bracket to the examiners and tells them
that a single win will make the
applicants a hunter the nine remaining
applicants arrive when the final phase
of the exam is held the chairman
explains to them that in order to pass
they only need one win and the losers
will move up the bracket until one
applicant fails
this way there will be eight new hunters
and one that will not pass
after the chairman completes his
explanation about their performances and
the rules on winning the final phase
begins the first match being between gon
and hanzo as soon as the fight starts
gone makes his move but hanzo
anticipates it and gone is staggered
from a hit hanzo tells gon about his
situation and asks him to give up but
gone refuses as hanzo continues to
strike him he tries to convince gon
again to surrender but gone was still
determined to keep up with the fight
while hanzo continues to strike
leorio was beginning to lose his temper
and warns hanzo he'll kill him and will
take gone's place instead however
because of the rules hanzo is not doing
anything wrong and gone will be the one
disqualified if leorio interferes gone
refuses to give up leaving hanzo no
other choice but to break his arm making
lyorio and kuropika enraged
gon soon gathers the strength to kick
hanzo in the face
however hanza recovers and pulls out a
sharp weapon from his sleeve and warms
goan that he'll cut his legs off if he
doesn't surrender but gon tries to
outsmart him by saying that it will be
disadvantageous for both of them as gom
will die due to excessive bleeding thus
disqualifying hanzo but hanzo outsmarts
him back saying that therefore he just
needs to apply again next year hanzo
gets serious and tells gone that he will
kill him and will just take the exam
next year as he stabs govern the
forehead
government speaks about his father that
he is a hunter and one day he will find
him but if he gives up now he may never
find him on seeing the unwavering
determination in gone's eyes hanzo
concedes defeat making gone the winner
of their match however gon refuses to
accept the way he won and keeps
pestering hanzo about his decision
out of other annoyance hanzo delivers a
hard punch knocking going unconscious
gon is the first applicant to pass the
287th hunter exam
gonna wakes from sleep with sadat
sitting beside his bed sadaz
congratulates gon on passing the hunter
exam through a handshake but gomez not
content on the results and declines
sad odds explains to him that he already
passed the exam and can no longer fail
he presents the hunter license adding
that whatever he wants to do with it
it's up to him in his decision
after hearing this explanation gone
accepts the hunter license and finally
shakes set outs hand
saddas tells gone that the exam is over
and tells him that the one who failed
was kilauea
god is eager to know the cause of
kilwa's failure and sadat tells him
about all the matches held after his
fight with hanzo after revealing the
applicants who passed and how each match
unfolded sadaz tells gome what happened
in the match between kiluah and gidera
learning that kirakore is actually his
older brother alumi kiluah was shocked
as illumi told him he's not fit to be a
hunter but an assassin killua told his
brother that he doesn't care about
having a license and that he just wants
to be friends with gon
upon hearing that illumi intended to
kill gone for he will only be a
hindrance to killua on his path to
becoming a full-time assassin
ulumi then walked toward the exit to go
to the room where gon was resting but
hanzo kurapika and lyorio stood up in
front of the door to stop a lumi he
approached his brother kiluah and asked
if he wanted to continue the match
kilowatt surrendered inferior's brother
and the situation of his friend after a
loomi won he told him that he was just
lying about killing gon
afterward the match of bodero and liurio
took place kilauea suddenly appeared
behind botero and killed him resulting
in his disqualification and failure of
the exam
knowing this gon goes to the place where
the others are having brief lessons
about being a hunter and confronts
illumi telling him he doesn't have the
right to be kilauea's brother he grabs
illumi's right arm and breaks it instead
of apologizing gon convinces illumi to
tell him where killwad is
kurapika explains that kiluah had been
acting differently during his match he
believes that illumi hypotized kilauea
into killing others the tarot tells them
that these are mere speculations and
there were no clear signs of
manipulation
illumi tries to touch gon but he becomes
wary and backs away after that matero
declares the seven examinees to be
hunters
outside gon confronts illumi again he
continues to ask the zoldiv to tell him
where kiluwar is illumi finally gives in
and tells them that kilwa is back home
at kyukiru mountain
after gon and his friends leave hizouka
appears behind illumi all locals know
where zoldix is so there's no harm if
gon knows it as well halloumi now knows
that gon has incredible potential that's
why hizoka waits for him to grow up but
that makes him more dangerous
illumi thinks of killing gon but hizoka
warns him if illumi touch is going he
will face the consequences saddaatz
gives gunas hunter license and tells him
a story about a hunter used to know who
would discover long forgotten ruins he
tells gon that this extraordinary hunter
was jing and even he tried to find him
but couldn't he longs to become a hunter
as amazing as jing and this makes gum
feel very good and he even blushes
inside the building karapika searches
for kyukiru mountain finding that it is
3722 meters high and located in the
republic of padokia later that day they
set off to kilwa's home and rescue them
the three gather information and ride a
tour bus
while traveling coco lou describes
kyukiru mountain and comments it's the
home of zolde family upon arriving at
the front gate which is also known as
the gate to hades coco informs them that
in order to enter they must pass through
the small door beside the security
checkpoint
adding that for all the people who
entered num came out alive hearing this
two punks taunt the guard who hands them
the key and they enter through the small
door claiming they'll get a reward for
taking pictures of the zoldics not long
after a huge furry hand throws their
corpses outside the wall
all the taurus and coco run in terror
except for gon kuropika and leoriog were
introduced to zebro
they learned that a beast named mike
kills intruders who enter beyond the
gate and only follows orders from the
zoldiff family
zebra refuses to give the key to them to
prevent them all from getting killed by
mike because of kuropika the group
learns that zebra isn't really a guard
but a cleaner of mike's messes and the
real entrance is the huge gate also
known as the testing gate and entering
through this gate will avoid mike from
attacking them
lyorio tries to open the gate with all
his strength but fails
after lyorio zebro demonstrates his
strength and opens the first door that
weighs two tons
gone realizing he doesn't have the
strength to open the door insists on
borrowing the key from zebro even though
kuropika and lyorio warn him against
doing so he won't listen so zebra speaks
to one of the butlers by phone and let's
go and speak to him but the butler
refuses to believe them and hangs up the
phone
frustrated gome decides to climb the
door using his fishing rod his friends
try to stop him but gone is too stubborn
and won't give up
zebra steps in once again and decides to
accompany the three inside the huge door
upon entering through the door zebra
calls on mike see mike's appearance the
three seem powerless and scared in spite
of that gone insists on meeting killua
and having zebra guide the way
they are then taken to the servants
quarters to stay there for a while they
meet sequin a servant of the zoldev
family after receiving insults from
sequence they are more determined to
open the testing gate using their own
strength zebra states that it will be
possible the little training they agree
to train and immediately start training
to their surprise everything is weighed
down an incredible amount of pounds even
an ordinary cup meanwhile kikayo and
kaludo visit kilauea in his cell while
he's being tortured by milikey his
mother informs him that his friends are
trying to open the gates and is
convinced that they will fail at opening
the gate while killua says otherwise
after days of hard training gon kurapika
and leorio successfully open the testing
gate
zebra points towards the mountain which
is the way to the mansion and they head
towards it
while walking the three are stopped by a
girl named canary the butler's
apprentice she draws a line across the
way and if any of them cross it she will
beat them up
gone makes countless tries but to no
avail canary wonders why he lets himself
get beaten like that
bellum says to canary that he just wants
to see kiluah canary is finally
convinced after hearing gone and as she
pleads him to help kilauea she is
knocked out by killwa's mother who is
watching from the bushes with kaluto she
thinks canaria has insulted the entire
zoldit family kiko then sees gon and
instantly recognizes him as a loomy told
her about him she delivers a message
from kilauea telling them that he can't
see them right now
gon kurapika and leorio tend to an
unconscious canary
meanwhile killua gets whipped by his
older brother miluki he accuses kilauea
of being too arrogant and killua
apologizes for stabbing his brother
during his escape the torture is cut
short when kikayo calls milky's phone
telling him that kilawa's friends are
near the butler's office milikey mocks
killua by asking their mother to drive
them away
killawa pulls one of his chains and
threatens to kill miluki if they even
touch his friends
kikayo introduces herself and kaludo
gonna asks why killua can't see them and
kikkail replies that kilwat entered
solitary confinement on his own will
she suddenly begins talking to herself
in haste and in worry
zeno enters the solitary confinement and
tells kilauea that he can leave he
easily breaks off the chains and tells
milky that he is not sorry but he does
feel bad about stabbing him before
kilauea could leave zeno added that his
father silva wants to see him millikid
feroza fit and accuses zeno of spoiling
kiluah he begins to praise himself and
nag about his latest invention a bomb
carrying mosquito that will explode once
the mosquito bites its target kikau
continues talking and eventually excuses
herself
gon ask her to tell kilauea that they
will stay canary awakens and volunteers
to take them to the butler's office
where there is a phone which can contact
the family
silva proceeds to talk to killua asking
what sort of people his friends are
they talk to each other while kikaio
comes running back home silva asks
killua if he wants to see his friends
he explains that he and killua are
different and he didn't realize that
until his son ran away
and so he asks kiluah one more time if
he wants to see his friends
kiluah says yes and solo makes a deal
with him never betray his friends he
sets kiluah free but kikaio stands in
his way saying that gon hirapika and
liurio already left
kiluah dismisses his mother and leaves
her being proud of him for glaring at
her and feeling his killing intent
kikaio confronts silva in his room and
blames him for setting kilua free when
he is finally home
silva believes that he will come home
one day because kilowatt is his son and
this was the end of part three
like always the links for the next parts
will be pinned in the comment section
be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell to not miss the next
part